the number one thing that's gonna change
your life the only thing that will
change your life change your business
change your money change your
relationship my life changed a couple
years ago when I discovered something
called the progress principle the best
definition of success I have ever heard
was one that Earl Nightingale originated
way back 1959 wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel is created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something greater inside you as
well you are a genius
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn some of the universal
laws of success
okay let's kick it off with law number
one trade your life for worthy goals
with Bob Proctor you know the law of
success is a pretty interesting concept
there's been books written on it stories
told on it lives have been spent looking
for it let's understand that everything
operates by law the whole universe
operates by law the best definition of
success I have ever heard was one that
Earl Nightingale originated way back
1959 he said success is the progressive
realisation of a worthy ideal let's
break that down for a moment success is
the progressive continually moving
progressive realization constant
awareness of a worthy ideal and ideal is
an idea that you have fallen in love
with and ideal is an idea that you're
intellectually emotionally and
physically involved with an ideal is an
idea that you fall in love with success
is the progressive realisation of a
worthy ideal so you don't ask are you
worthy of the idea are you worthy of the
good is it worthy of you now now you're
getting in to love success is it worthy
of you to see what you're gonna do is
trade your life you're trading your life
for whatever it is you're going after so
you want to make up your mind whatever
your goal happens to be whatever you are
pursuing make certain it's worthy of you
because you're chained trading your life
for it
the law of success calls for you to
continually moving toward a
predetermined objective in life and
bringing your life in harmony with the
laws that govern the entire universe law
number two used the progress principle
with Mel Robbins my life changed a
couple years ago when I discovered
something called the progress principle
it is a principle that was written about
in the Harvard Business Review it's
based on a tremendous amount of research
done by a professor over there and what
she determined is that people that feel
happy and successful and fulfilled by
their lives and work they all have one
thing in common they feel as though
they're making progress on something
that matters so I read this little bit
of research and I started applying it to
my life and what I do as stupid as it
sounds it really works I don't focus on
balancing everything I focus on just
making sure that I make progress on one
thing a day that's right you heard me
one thing a day that matters to me now
if I can make progress on one thing a
day that matters to me then I can let go
and let the rest of my day get hijacked
by kids by spouse by phone calls by
emails by social media by all kinds of
things that come up and tend to hijack
your day when you're a busy person when
you have a family when you're married
when you got a lot going on and so by
focusing on one thing a day
I feel the sense of control in the sense
of progress that science tells us will
make you happy and make you feel more
confident and actually make you more
effective at getting things done it also
frees me up to be more present with my
kids also if you want to have more
confidence check out my 254 series they
are free the links Joyner in the
description below
so while you're in this passionate state
that's where you make decisions you
might want to get honest with yourself
like instead of doing this via
billionaire or do this do you really
because you can make it happen
you actually can look at all the idiots
that are making money you can make honey
so I start to study myself I found most
people don't know who they are they
really don't long number three is raise
your standards with Tony Robbins the
number one thing that's gonna change
your life the only thing that will
change your life change your business
change your money change your
relationship because you must raise your
standard now I know that sounds boring
stupid basic but it's the truth the only
thing that changes our life long term is
when we raise our standards what does
that mean that sounds so boring and dumb
it means that all of us in life have
things we want we don't get what we want
we get what we have to have remember I
said earlier we all get what we tolerate
in ourselves and other people but when
you're no longer willing to tolerate
something that's when your life changes
the difference in people is their
standards period the difference in
people is their standards period and
what I mean by standards everyone in the
world has a list of things they think
they should do I should lose weight I
should work out I should spend more time
with my kids I should work harder I
should make more calls I should I should
I should I should and then you know what
people don't do their sheds and they get
mad at themselves and they when I call
[ __ ] all over themselves they beat them
scope up about it
what changes people is when you should
becomes a must when suddenly the thing
you said should happen has to happen
that's when human beings change it's
like if you want to take the
Island and you're the head of the army
and you want to take the art Island the
most powerful way to take the island is
burn the boats because if there's no way
to go back it's amazing what happens
when it's a must to do something versus
a should that's what makes human being
succeed and law number four the last one
before a very special bonus clip is
practice gratitude with EDM Island I had
a really good friend of mine I went to
lunch and he said yeah I don't know who
this guy is here in front of me and he
goes let me ask you a question honestly
right now what are you grateful for and
at the lunch I said jex nothing brother
there's nothing good in my life right
now and I'm not exaggerating this to you
when I tell you this and this is a
factual story as I'm mouthing these
words two people walked in with an older
man both of them clearly were fighting
cancer somehow both had lost their hair
one of the ladies had a bonnet on and
they were barely moving in both walked
by our table and gave me the most warm
greeting the warmest smile as a stranger
and he goes that's pretty freaking
pathetic you can't find anything in your
life to be grateful for right now and on
the drive home I'm not kidding you I
started to stack gratitude I started to
take inventory because if you can find
things to be grateful for in that space
man as your life gonna be rich when
there really are external things to be
grateful for
so my first mechanism out of that space
was honestly to stack the things I was
grateful for and I started reinforcing
it over and over and over again and what
happens is there's this reticular
activating system in our brains right
and all of a sudden because that's the
messaging I was giving myself all of a
sudden all these things start to come
into my awareness that I'm grateful for
I start to magnetized to myself some
people that I needed to find into my
life and that was the next layer I
started to see things to be grateful for
my health my fitness people who loved me
and what it did is it changed my state
when I stacked gratitude I changed what
I did in the morning and I changed what
I did in the evening and so somehow by
grabbing control of my morning and by
grabbing control of my evening I got
some measure of control over the middle
of my day I was an out of control person
back in those days meaning this I woke
up worried stressed fearful and I
immediately start thinking about a bill
I had to pay something that was wrong
and
in a state of reaction to begin every
sound talking within six minutes of
waking up six seconds most people
listening to this that's what they do I
said I got to grab control of my morning
and I set up routines in my morning
maybe they serve me maybe they didn't
but they were things I could deliver on
doing for myself and so not only do that
give me control over the day but I
started to stack my self-confidence too
now I have a special bonus slip on how
to manage the energy in your life with
done the Pawnee that I think you're
going to enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point landing questions
let's go from just watching the video to
taking action here we go
question number one what are three
things that you are grateful for right
now number two where do you need to
raise the standards in your business and
life and number three how can you apply
the progress principle to your business
and if you like this video and will take
action after watching it give me a
hashtag believe down the comments as
well learning how to manage your energy
is really really important in life and
one of the most important ways to do it
is to really look at the people around
you and you can simplify and this is a
very simplified view obviously we're
doing it very quickly who are people
that are uplifting in your life and who
are people that drain you and the people
that drain you I call them energy
vampires and sometimes these people are
colleagues friends associates and
sometimes their families and relatives
as well if you find that these energy
vampires are inherently energy vampires
or not because they're going through a
hard time in life and might be going
through a trouble period for a couple
years those are the people that you want
to have more tolerance with but people
who are energy vampires of all the time
then these are people you want to let go
out as a lot of them yes and you want to
have the courage to do that and most
people can do that with friends or
associates or clients but when it comes
to relatives and families like it's much
harder and I think if you value your
life enough then you'll do it you'll do
it
if you want to know the five Universal
skills that will make you rich check out
the video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there which you need is the
one thing I talk to my book if I could
go back and you could only give me one
skill to begin with and I had to build
from all of it